are we going to war because Donald Trump
is sending troops to Saudi Arabia this
is a story we've been following and in
fact we've been following there's sort
of like three stories at least that
relate to this and I'll tell you what
they are in a moment but stunningly
there has been an extremely small amount
of coverage of this from corporate media
this is a major major story and
intertwined are number one the story of
Donald Trump claiming remember he said
he was the guy who wasn't going to start
wars Hillary would start wars and then
as soon as he became president even
military action against Venezuela was
suddenly on the table among other
countries so that's story number one
story number two is Trump as the
subservient military-industrial complex
tool in the context of Saudi Arabia
story number three is the implicit
support or at least indifference to
Saudi Arabia's devastatingly disgusting
war on Yemen and we recently had sort of
added on to this the forced resignation
of national security advisor John Bolton
combined with some Saudi facilities
being attacked and the question that we
had last week was what is Donald Trump
going to do he tweeted he would do
whatever Saudi Arabia wants but what is
he actually going to do well we've now
learned that Donald Trump has approved
sending troops to Saudi Arabia of course
in the context of blaming Iran for the
attacks against Saudi facilities which
may be true Iran has so far denied it it
may have maybe Iran we don't really know
at this point in time the Pentagon says
we're talking about not multiple
thousands of troops although they're not
saying exactly the number that could
mean several hundred that could mean a
couple thousand maybe we don't know and
we're told that the presence of these
troops in Saudi Arabia is going to be
primarily defensive which of course
we've heard before there's also a plan
to expedite delivery of military
equipment to Saudi Arabia and to the
United Arab Emirates fast-tracking the
growing military-industrial complex
under trump visa vie Saudi Arabia which
we've talked about many many times big
arms deals Trump loves them we've talked
about it before they are also
considering
a quote indefinite aircraft carrier
deployment to the region now indefinite
is definitely a word that we've grown
accustomed to since 9/11 when it comes
to military engagements and Donald Trump
ultimately is just going to do whatever
Saudi Arabia wants just like he tweeted
that he would last week US Defense
Secretary mark Esper saying in response
to the kingdom's request the president
has approved the deployment of US forces
which will be defensive in nature and
primarily focused on air and missile
defense mark Esper is confirming that
Donald Trump is doing what Saudi Arabia
asks and why wouldn't he Trump tweeted
that he would do that last week remember
this when Trump tweeted quote Saudi
Arabia oil supply was attacked there is
reason to believe we know the culprit
are locked and loaded depending on
verification but are waiting to hear
from the kingdom as to who they believe
was the cause of this attack and under
what terms we would proceed Trump said
he would do whatever Saudi Arabia wants
and Mark Esper is confirming that Donald
Trump is doing what Saudi Arabia wants
now there are two interpretations of
Donald Trump's deployment of troops and
possibly of an aircraft carrier one is
an interpretation sort of of relief
because Donald Trump is merely setting
up some defense around Saudi Arabia in
and around Saudi Arabia rather than
ordering immediate retaliatory attacks
against Iran that would be the most
benign interpretation of this the other
interpretation is that this is just
pushing the door open with troops and an
aircraft carrier to further instigate
Iran so that at some point in the future
may be timed conveniently with the
upcoming election of 2020 Donald Trump
can use it as an opportunity to really
start a proper war potentially to the
benefit of his re-election campaign at
least if history serves us in figuring
out the the cost benefit of military
engagements during re-election it
actually tends to be a pretty good thing
for presidents seeking re-election now
remember that we were told that Hillary
Clinton was going to go to war
with everybody but Donald Trump wasn't
Trump wouldn't even consider ridiculous
military engagements like Hillary
supposedly was going to the trumpet said
it Trump said it and in reality we've
seen Donald Trump threatened military
action against North Korea against
Venezuela against Iran against Syria I
can't even remember the entire list at
this point and of course in the
background or questions about Trump's
relationships with different countries
and how they influence foreign policy
Saudi Arabia there are questions there
Russia in relation to Syria and
Venezuela and there are others so the
number of disgusting elements to this
story is large and corporate media is
barely interested and there is Donald
Trump's implicit support of the Saudi
Arabian humanitarian crisis war on Yemen
arguably impeachable support we've
talked about that before that's never in
the news even though it's
extraordinarily disgusting
there's the sickening military defense
of Saudi Arabia going on right now
despite Trump previously saying that
Saudi Arabia has to take care of itself
when Obama was president of course and
then you have the continued military
industrial complex sale of weapons to
Saudi Arabia even in the context of
murder journalists from all Jamaal
khashoggi who Donald Trump whose murder
Donald Trump has done very very little
about could this be more backwards and
in the end this is just more
confirmation that Donald Trump when it
comes right down to it has no actual
political philosophy he has no
underlying moral code that informs his
behavior war is bad he says if he can
say Hillary would get us into Wars but
he can keep us out war is bad if george
w bush went into iraq and trump can now
say it was a bad idea all along even
though at the time he called into the
howard stern show and says he would have
done the same thing or war is bad except
if it will potentially help his
reelection campaign or make him look
strong in his own eyes or distract from
his crimes and grift and self enrichment
through the presidency
the end I don't know right now whether
this is the lead-up to war with Iran but
it's particularly disgusting beyond just
like the general militarism that we're
seeing in as a feature of what Donald
Trump is open to because it's number one
all in the defense of a country that we
should be reducing ties to in the first
place and number two coming at the
expense as usual just again with Trump
these decisions and this infrastructure
is coming at the exchange at the cost of
our own sovereignty we are exporting
more and more of the decisions we make
with our military and with our diplomacy
to other countries and that's
extraordinarily concerning and barely a
peep about it from corporate media